where we left off in the last video
world war two had begun in September of
1939 Germany invades Poland followed
shortly by France and Great Britain
declaring war on Germany followed
shortly by the Soviet Union themselves
under Stalin's leadership also invading
Poland and laying claim to their sphere
of influence and so now we are going to
enter into 1940 and we're going to see
that in 1940 in 1941
things only start to accelerate in the
Nazis and as will soon call them the
Axis powers favour so in April in April
in April you have the Germans invade
Denmark Denmark and Norway Denmark and
Norway let me make sure I spell that
right so Germany's invades Denmark and
Norway
this is April of 1940 and then you have
May of 1940 Germany invades the
Netherlands in Belgium so Netherlands
let me just write let me write the Low
Countries sometimes called because this
place this the land in the Netherlands
right over here is very close to sea
level or sometimes even below sea level
Low Countries the Low Countries so
invades Netherlands invades Belgium kind
of a kind of very similar what happened
in World War one were that's kind of how
Germany gets to France and then in June
in June Italy enters the fray Italy
which we've seen before Italy declares
war Italy in the war Benito Mussolini in
the run-up to World War two was getting
closer and closer to Adolf Hitler and so
in June Italy declares war on the Allies
on Great Britain and France and so now
Italy so now Italy is formally in World
War two and as soon as Italy joins World
War two you start having all of these
skirmishes out here between Italy's
colonies and it's kind of where their
ruling colonial II in Libya and in Egypt
where where the British are essentially
are essentially in control so you start
having all of these skirmishes across
the board of the Egyptian and
to be in border so that was that was
June and I actually June Italy's into
the war and then shortly thereafter
France Falls to Germany so this wasn't
like World War 1 where we get kind of
embroiled in all this trench warfare
that lasts over the duration of most of
the war very quickly little think about
it this is only where only what's eight
nine months into the war France Falls a
major power France Falls to Germany and
they install with Vichy France which at
first is in control for the part of
France roughly the part of France that
I'm highlighting this is a town of Vichy
which was the capital of Vichy France
which is why it's called that and then
later the rest of what's called free
France Falls to Germany later in the war
in 1942 but things are really are really
not looking good things are really not
looking good for looking good for the
Allies so France Falls France Falls
Falls to Germany the establishment of
Vichy France which is essentially
controlled by the Germans and then then
in July Germany begins bombing Britain
so bombing bombing Britain the famous
Battle of Britain which was actually
called the Battle of Britain even before
it began within Churchill today where
you have to prepare for the upcoming
Battle of Britain and Germany starts
bombing Great Britain and then things
get only worse from there so in
September in September the axis forms
with Japan forming with Japan joining
Japan signs the tripartite pact and so
it becomes the axis forms between Japan
Italy in Germany signs signs tripartite
tripartite part tripartite pact so now
in Japan's in the mix and since France
has already fallen to Germany so Japan
is now formally part of the axis with
Italy and Germany and since France has
fallen to Germany Japan says hey maybe
we can go after some of France's
colonies in particular French
no China which we now refer to as
Vietnam in Cambodia and so shortly
thereafter Japan Japan attacks French
Indochina so things are not really
looking good at all and it only gets it
only gets worse from there in November
in November so once again we're a little
over a year into the war now we're
entering where we're entering the end of
1940 in November Hungary and Romania are
pressured to join the axis so hungry and
Romania joined the axis so as we see is
we kind of are leaving 1940 things are
not looking good at all for the Allied
powers you see this map and I'm
apologizing for my messiness it's
looking more and more and more red the
only slightly you know kind of saving
grace for the Allied powers it's what's
happening over here in North Africa is
that eventually the end of 1940 the
British are able to drive the Libyans
are able to drive the Italians back into
Libya so let me do this in a different
color I'll do blue for the Allies so the
British are able to drive the Italian
forces back into Libya and they
essentially are able to defeat the
Italians in Libya and but that's only
going to take us into 1941 which we'll
talk about in the next video where the
Germans send reinforcements under the
command of Rommel and they're able to
drive the British back again into Egypt
and we'll see in 1941 Germany and the
Axis powers only become more and more
and more aggressive as we enter the end
of 1941 we'll see the entry of the u.s.
into World War two